nell'episodio precedente sei diventato
la castagna è un trita castagna amico
mio gioco migliore del mondo fair non
avrei visto delle persone briccone tutti
animali a memoria ma questo è un buon
giorno e oltre con ti prego vai borbon
forcello te siamo in data usi coi
cuscini e nostra figlia che non è questa
non è più cancella la scusa che noi
siamo entrati dalla finestra
ecco nella finestra ok beh non era così
camera non è un tipo così bisogna
caricata ma cosa cacchio è cioè
lampadario sotto una tenda che casa è
non era così accetta burello carri a
muro dove cacchio stiamo da niente a
casa mia di casarsa è diventata una roba
di cuscini e basta cerchino di cose
cos'è non lo so chi fa sono giocattoli
bosnia è il mondo che si muove
ok va bene non è più camera di nostra
figlia bianca velo da tempo però è
un'altra cosa
c'è un altro gioco più avanti a tutti vi
collegare cosi arrivavo questi sono gli
hacker che questo creepers un creamer va
bene beh non è facile fare la gara
pensavo fosse peggio a devi cercare di
prendere il segnale è successo
ebbe un ciò che ti ma che studino ci
hanno risucchiati nell'iperspazio
tecnologico ed eravamo in casa reale né
no ma che palle
questi sono stati tutti i colori o
merd.a è il pupazzo bru bru bru lunga la
blue bubble mare quello che io posso
dirti è che dovunque vicino vedo la sua
ombra guarda ecco ha fatto anche sottile
si vabbè ma che fai ma poi ecco no ho
pensato questo nuovo gadget di questo
livello
io ti posso in giganteggiare e quando lo
fai cambia anche la tua voce
metti lo sono nel naso e questo ciò io e
gravi scarponi cammino sui muri loro già
sanno che lì serve comunque io ne so già
ste cose perché è uguale della cresce
del clan certo ricordi anche questo
certe tesi che nazionali o più uguale
uguale
ok siano i gravi scarponi l'impiccio ava
tu puoi farlo quando vuoi bellissimo io
posso camminare sui muri paci che cosa
poi però solo piccolissimo sì io adesso
sono sul soffitto tipo vieni anche tu
non so come 26 qua parole ma è
bellissimo
no vabbè ragazzi ogni volta andiamo
avanti c'è sempre accusa la mega
pazzesco è fighissimo
e ora orari schiacciare il tasto per
fattibile
se madonna ragazze arrivo io che son
ignota provenienza la prima pensiamo a
ciò che succede in questi giorni è no il
frigo però questo secondo se non avrebbe
senso arrivo ma che filippo sentire in
tutti i posti c'è una pila metti la pila
ora va o dio ho fatto schiacciato il
tipo un ascensore ma mi sa di sì ora se
ci sarà qualcosa penso è che
l'abitazione ci dobbiamo ficcare dentro
fino a 100 center no va bene è
bellissimo tu sei entrato nel chiostro
vi farà quanto cacchio sono grossi come
sono piccolissimo ma non sono entrato in
un portale cosa succede qui si intrica
il cervello non sto capendo niente ma
che sto facendo nulla
cos'è sta roba che se sto capendo niente
no vabbè vado a me è veramente un casino
sto mondo che cacchio devo poi sono
entrati in un portale solo fare delle
cose
ok non so neanche dove sto andando ma ci
sto andando è no presidente di
distaccare andare sull'altro coso di
bianco ok ma non solo anche come perché
i cessi ttt salti e poiché attacchi
all'altro alla r1 ricorda il salto
ok ci trovano e ti attaccato nessuno mi
sembra un po esagerato per essere una
cameretta questo però va bene infatti a
tutti i portali dobbiamo attivare una
cameretta non e marmi ha però una volta
attivate tutte secondo me altro che toy
story provo un casino e supermario
chiamo yes
io vado di sopra non sono anche perché
io mi sembra un pelo eccessivo
ok aveva schivare gli ostacoli a vicenda
io non sono molto buono marco io perché
chi guarda collector
questa è veramente se impazzì comunque
non aspetta aspetta ora ora poiché così
vai vai no naja ora però spostiamolo
anche quello spostare anche il papa più
bello grande del mondo che è poi si
lasciano e poi io ho fatto io
ecco vedi ti sei pure lamentato nel tema
gabinetto noi abbia ormai capiamo i
personaggi lega
il mio personaggio sta facendo cose
strunk affari come faccio credo che tu
debba ai marchi silos 8 vede e ci farà
ritornare lì sono mai che ci da
trasporto e non male vero
yes man portare ragazzo stati bravi
idraulici nostra voce molto più dei
quali quote che questo no questo quasi
sicuro c'è un acaro sopra perfetto brodo
metrò superman si sono più o meno non so
cosa sia ma ci vado meno difficile del
previsto
sto a fare qua io non ho mai capito come
lei mail a 0 è bellissimo non si è perso
alla fine ma dimmi tu baci o young rider
dato questa tua di rimuoverlo ad una
sinistra vedi che comunque 60 al diploma
66ma righe comune arriva ovunque nella
vita ci sappiamo fare però non si può
dire di certo il contrario ma infatti bo
alla fine ero solo un numero quanto dice
voluto per programma
ma resta roma infatti pazze è purtroppo
è come faccio adesso pacis
sì sì per programmassero persone sono
diventati pazzi ci ai pazienti se esco
troppo bello hi fi casta batteria ma
sono così le targhe dei come no ce
l'abbiamo fatto per questo è stato mi
chiama abbiamo abbiamo veramente
padroneggiato tutto questo era molto
semplice
be nice è un altro portale andato a oggi
chiama portali praticamente si limita
che questi sono gli ultimi perché no per
forza e che sono già tanti ok secondo
livello a destra destra questo ma devi
entrare tu una porticina minuscola è un
flipper vai brother un aiuto e ti devo
stare qua non credo proprio titolo
sparare la bros per sabato by 20
disattivo le barriere ben 6 cagato nelle
mutande brother ok perfetto fatto bene
ma non può fare niente volevo fare il
pirla ma è veramente facile scherza ride
i vigili visto mi stai proprio di amber
non ce la faremo mai
e adesso non ci sto provando dell'area
fine vai ti amo come hai fatto prima
bravate fatto che qua basta validi
sparsi qua ma capito che ce l'ho pensato
dai non faccio pirla aiuto da farlo però
scusami
ora capisco però lo farei ma aveva
almeno su prova a cavarsela il dritto
devide veramente resistere addio
per me non c'è più è lì perché al centro
gli è molto bravo
la minchia provini più grave è successo
è lui si cambia la voce quando pare
difficile farsi mi chiedo distrutto
molto è stato qua ci vuole un ombrello
mi serve un ombrello l'ombrello che da
melo arrivato a tu puoi farlo che andrà
fa mi fa mie brame se prefetto a
spiegarmi la trasferta dove mi botti
tutto ecco come mi confondo e così non
altre invenzioni b ma che vorrebbe
infatti si incrocia il cervello ecco il
quadro è normale anche a me belli sono
un con gli portale buono fatto adesso ne
mancano altri un altro altri due ma io
non capisco nella storia che sta
succedendo niente siamo in cameretta a
ocre camera grossa ci è passato anche
nell'iperspazio sono soprano fatto anche
stargate in sto posto in poi lei ne
manca uno che di questo quello d'oro
quello d'oro quello d'oro quello d'oro
abbiamo cuscini agolo va bene mi piace
non è male come possa dare anche su
questi sì sto male non prove ed errori
giornali qualsiasi deve pagare il gioco
considerati pop rock grazie a forse sì
ma esecutiva di a porca trottola ti dà
negativamente a me almeno a niente
note ridarà nel senso di far esplodere
tutti a casa mia ok ok libro arrivo c'è
sul salvagente cazzaro una ciambella
tisa così bello poi è qua mi devi far
saltare come torbido però dall'altra
parte
ecco
ma ho capito si è capito allora aspetta
fiction sta dall'altra parte stai
d'altra parte si rimpicciolisce di
minuscolo e forse ho esagerato nei
paraggi che anni gi oh
niente normale eccolo gli hole in my
brain tu sei un pazzo
sono veramente molto sveglio di tanto
lorenzo pazzo lorenzo basso occhio che
poi c'è qualcosa adesso è entrato
credere piccolo a di agganci giovanna
gancia vicenda vai a volte che si
aggancia anche a me quindi possiamo fare
ok sempre disabili semplicissimo con
nonchalance di essi abbiamo fatto anche
l'ultimo ora boss fight controllo
scimmia cigna sicuro probabile è
dimostrazione del quale i pochi vini
piccioli scozzese
l'avevo detto e roba simile ecco
facciamo mi concederà stupro e schiaccia
di che però mi sta seguendo l'altro vi
sta facendo un male voglia che non
riesca a schivarlo vai che cosa che si
capisce cosa c'è qua non lo so ma visto
veramente schiaccia l'occhio a tutte ma
lo posso colpire dalla se non faccio
conti dall'altra arrivo sarà minchia
come lo fu schivando non lo so cazzo
stai fermo a babbo lunare se colpito
gravi babbo occhio fallo riuscire di
nuovo i tasti di voluminosi tu vai sono
pressi alzano da kemal è fortissimo
non ti far colpire di nuovo se non mori
un bel maniero un sacco ma da mamma rai
di fare quadrato 4 4 4 2 dove dovrà per
forza un po più il largo
io vado a prenderti il tasto ma perché
sono io prendo io e vieni qua di qua
perfetto mai di aspettare che si
demoralizzi nei raggi x poi cavalca b2
ecco visto che non così l'ufficio
abbiamo finito
bravo non stati con in verticale per
avere nice
facendo così si piglia tutto il danno in
faccia madonna che male scimmia
maledetta bravo michele però pure fisi
spaccato il cool asta scimmie a babbo
lunare babbo la mamma no perché ci sei
ma insieme together ottimo come agli
invertiti
ottimo bellissime brutto picchiava
bolgare all'evento al 106 viso lo fai
prove ma tu sei l'idea base che ti
giganti ci distrugge lo sto continuando
a schivare roba quindi veloce aia devo
resistere mentre profitti centro di
sabini ed è fortissimo trovi fra gli sta
facendo un culo quadro di muoversi tra
gli ultimi scarico east rigoristico
passeggiava io resisto lo prometto
questo punto pure loro super 0 con merda
però nella suo cavallo aia come ho detto
mi sto facendo un culo quadrati giuro
visto sbrigando vai tranquillo no no una
caduta o che ci hai fatto oddio ma mi
sono veramente sfacciato ha perso della
navicella ma ero mai spaccato il culo
siamo noi dentro ma di gente in quanto
pare sì evvai
bravo torcia lo baido chiaro va al
momento di spaccarmi il kulm isola
dobbiamo combatterlo noi così si si si
pensa del contrario
ecco io lo seguono tu porca traver lo
colpisci il fatto è che non lo riguarda
è stato estate stampa destra destra
guardi il radar dove sono io eccolo
doveri può capirlo ma che figata come la
proclamata sta roba è bellissimo infatti
ma il fatto è che perché ha sempre lo
scudo fa proprio in centro qua in centro
probabile che ci fanno mai perfetto uomo
alle altre vite tre studi sono stati
fortissimi no allargato fatto tirare lag
ma campellino per colorare babbo lunare
che cavo e riina
[Musica]
e quindi torniamo nella cameretta piace
lillo in basso a destra gara spuntino
padre stacco del gioco è davanti a voi
se mi spunta quello di piccoli bruciato
libro da invece no non sfruttato blog
dalla canon esistono per lei sai che lo
assisteva foglio come sta porca [ __ ]
che naso grosso o un naso grosso o un
naso grosso noi poveri a salvare la star
ucciderà niente o quasi è frizza vi si è
raffreddato le non è preso nota
oppure stato divertentissimo
[Musica]